hello everybody and welcome to the
second keynote presentation in our
inaugural precision medicine event
you're about to hear from Kathy Hudson
from the NIH discussing the precision
medicine initiative and I'll give kathy
a full and proper introduction in just a
couple of minutes so hello again I'm
Kevin Davis the publisher of caen en
chemical and engineering news published
by the american chemical society and one
of the co-organizers along with lab
roots of this inaugural and exciting
precision medicine in conference today's
web seminar is presented and hosted by
lab roots partners they're the leading
social networking website and my
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning my organization's senior media
group is the official media partner for
today's event and we're delighted to of
party would lab roots to co organized
and helped plan the agenda Kathy Hudson
may be our second keynote today
following a scintillating presentation
from Eric shat just a moment ago but she
was literally the first name on our
agenda when we started planning this
event several months ago so we can't
wait to were to bring along a couple of
housekeeping notes before we welcome
Kathy the webcast is designed to be
interactive we look forward to taking
your questions which you can enter in
the Q&A box at any time during Kathy's
presentation and we'll try to get to as
many of those as we possibly can so just
click on the button the Q&A button in
the lower left-hand side of your screen
and and fire away you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the window and if you encounter any
technical issues during the broadcast
please hit the support button top right
of your screen and and follow
instructions there this is an
educational webinar and we're offering
continuing education credits
so after the webinar is over if you're
interested in receiving credit for your
attendance please click on the CD button
located bottom left-hand corner of the
web page and follow the process for
obtaining your your credits we're
required because this is a sea of enter
to de close any disclose any potential
conflicts of interest I will disclose
that I'm on the psychic Advisory Board
of pathway genomics and on the speaker's
bureau for the Harry Walker agency but
neither constitute such a complex and
kathy has no relevant financial
relationships of complex to declare so
we got that out of the way so it gives
me a real pleasure to introduce and
welcome Kathy Hudson who I've known for
a long long time and admire greatly
she's the Deputy Director for science
outreach and policy for the NIH and
serves as a senior advisor to NIH
director Francis Collins she's leading
the planning and creation of President
Obama's precision medicine initiative
cohort program having previously been a
key architect of the NI axially of the
NIH brain initiative Kathy's previously
served as NIH chief of staff held senior
leadership roles at mcats the National
Center for advancing translational
sciences as well as a NHGRI and she's
the founding director of the genetics
and Public Policy Center at Johns
Hopkins John Hopkins University so Kathy
without further ado we want to thank you
again for making time in your hectic
schedule to join us today and really
look forward to your update and thoughts
on the precision medicine initiative so
over to you and now thank you carrying a
knife
thank you for that introduction I'm
Kevin that's nice to see you I'll be it
in a small box on my screen so i am
going to talk a little bit about the
precision medicine initiative and it's
great to follow eric i didn't get to
watch Eric this morning but certainly
know him and his work and I trust that
he provided a great set of insights
about the promise of precision medicine
in general and so what I should say to
sort of get started here is that I'm
going to be talking about the precision
medicine initiative as announced by the
president a little over a year ago and
specifically I'm going to talk about the
precision medicine initiative cohort
program so the cohort program is one
part of the initiative and the
initiative is one part of a bigger
landscape surrounding precision medicine
and precision medicine advances please
note i i'm on twitter and i tend to
tweet almost exclusively about precision
medicine and there's going to be a lot
of things happening over the next 24
hours actually in precision medicine so
i encourage you to to follow me and
you'll get updates that way so by way of
background i'm going to try to get my
slide to advance there we go so a little
over a year ago the president in the
State of the Union address on january
twentieth and then ten days later at the
White House announced that he was
launching this precision that is an
initiative and at that time we didn't
have a lot of clarity about exactly what
this initiative would entail and so I'm
going to tell you a little bit about
what we did in order to put together a
really specific scientific blueprint for
this initiative but clearly his
enthusiasm in the state of the union was
received nearly every member of the
House and Senate present there at the
State of the Union stood up and
applauded together and of course that's
a rarity and then ten days later he
invited a large number of patients and
researchers and others to the White
House to talk about this exciting
initiative so the broad overarching
mission for the precision medicine
initiative is here really to usher in a
new
of medicine in which the prevention
diagnostics and treatment are tailored
to an individual not just their genes
but their lifestyle environment and the
like so one question that we ask
ourselves and we get asked about the
precision that is an initiative which
I'll talk about is why now why did we
pick this particular moment to launch
this initiative and the reasons are
really multifold and they have a lot to
do with the alignment of both
technological advances and culture
changes in culture that really make this
the right time to launch this initiative
my boss Francis Collins about a decade
ago published a paper i think it was in
nature in which he said now is the time
to have a gene and environment cohort to
really understand how gene by
environment interactions influence
health and disease and he was flatly
wrong because that was not the time
sequencing was too expensive we didn't
have the kinds of technologies that we
have today and importantly we didn't
have the the right set of relationships
and to manage having participants as
true partners in the research enterprise
so today we have engaged participants
who are impatient to see advances we
have electronic health records which
certainly didn't exist a decade ago and
are improving with every day in every
week we have mobile technologies that
allow us to monitor and others to
monitor our whereabouts our activity
level various sorts of biological
measures and those certainly are
advancing rapidly and then of course we
have genomic information and the cost of
sequencing continuing to plummet and
making that more and more affordable and
more and more integrated into healthcare
and then we have big data and data
science and the ability to have an
interconnected world in which scientific
data can be retrieved and made available
to researchers basically anywhere in the
world properly so that enables us then
to build
those technologies and an ecosystem
that's really going to have to work
closely together to make this initiative
work and that means that includes the
participants themselves people who want
to share information about themselves to
advance research and advance health and
medicine we need researchers the
government community leaders and health
care providers all to be working
together to make this initiative work so
the initiative in general is intended to
enroll a large number of people from
across the United States to agree to
provide their information for research
purposes and in order to lay out the
scientific plan and what would really be
required to put together this cohort dr.
Collins put together a working group
which I had the honor of co-chairing
with some colleagues and that group met
over a period of a number of months had
many workshops on specific topics which
are listed here on this slide and those
workshops actually our webcast and are
archived and you can get them from the
precision medicine initiative webpage at
NIH we also put out several requests for
information on specific topics and
during the midst of our work we did a
survey in conjunction with the
foundation for the NIH in order to
understand preliminary there's much more
to know about what are the public's
attitudes about should we create such a
cohort would they participate in such a
cohort what would be their aspirations
and their concerns so um that working
group generated its report just in
September of 2015 and since then we
pivoted very quickly from a planning
mode to an implementation mode I'm going
to talk a little bit about both the
recommendations of the working group and
then what we are doing in real time
today in implementing this this plan so
one of the first things we did in the
working group was to really explore what
are the scientific opportunities
it would be made possible by having a
research cohort of a million or more
people from across the United States
what questions could we uniquely ask and
answer in such a research cohort and
that's important in order to focus on
obtaining the right data focusing on
high-value data that's going to be
enable us to answer these questions so
some of these examples are listed here
I'm particularly focused on being able
to make sure that we always keep front
and center being able to ask and answer
questions in the short-term the
medium-term and the longer term that are
going to return value for the research
community community but more importantly
for the individual participants in the
cohort and so I particularly like the
second example here about being able to
obtain and return to cohort participants
genetic variants that are responsible
for drug response so I won't read
through these opportunities specific
opportunities you can see down here so
what's the cohort going to look like a
cohort some people objected to using the
word cohort when we first got started
but it seems like it has stuck a cohort
while used mostly in the scientific
community just basically means a group
of people with a shared experience and
really that's what we're looking for
here is a group of people from across
America who are going to have a shared
experience together in collaborating
with researchers on this enterprise so
we hope to have 1 million or more
volunteers that will be broadly
reflective of the diversity of the
United States it will not be
statistically or epidemiologically
representative we've tried that before
and have found that if the juice is not
worth the squeeze there in terms of cost
and scientific meaning we have a strong
focus on underrepresented groups and
really look to the development of this
cohort as providing a research
infrastructure that will really help us
tackle
on health disparities in a much more
effective way than has previously been
possible this is going to be a
longitudinal cohort so we're going to
have an ongoing partnership with our
participants and then we're going to
have two methods of enrollment one
through healthcare provider
organizations which is more familiar to
us than the other which I'll talk about
in just a second and we have put out
solicitations for these healthcare
provider organizations have received
applications and we'll be making those
awards in June and I'll show you a
timeline in a little bit also included
in healthcare provider organizations are
federally qualified health centers and
so we are really excited to be able to
partner with community health centers
who provide health care to the most
vulnerable amongst us and really have an
over-representation of underrepresented
individuals and groups as among their
patients we have never had a partnership
with federally qualified health centers
to do research at this scale before so
this is a really interesting and
challenging opportunity we're excited to
get started with that and then we want
to make sure that there is an I'll come
back to this repeatedly substantial
participant engagement at every stage
and that included in the working group
process so initially within this cohort
we want to have a core data set the data
set will be collected and stored
centrally and made available in real
time for research purposes we want to
make sure that we're possible the data
that we collect actually is comparable
to data that others have collected so
thank the UK biobank the million
veterans program and other similar
studies across the globe we want to be
able to where possible use existing data
standards and data models where we're
possible and we want to start with a
small but extraordinarily valuable data
set and then add on as the cohort
evolves and emerges in partnership with
our participants that we can add on
additional data sets
over time we don't want to be all things
to all people at the get-go we're likely
to collapse under our own weight if we
do that so we want self-reported
measures what we're not calling
participant provided information and
that will be among amongst the first
data set that we collect and I'll talk a
little bit more about that we want to
get a baseline health exam and for
people who are participating through
health care providers that will be easy
I wonder if I can go backwards I can go
backwards so I sort of skipped over in
the methods of enrollment the direct
volunteer so I talked about the health
care providers the federally qualified
health centers but I didn't say that we
really have an ambition to enable any
person anywhere in the United States to
be able to raise their hand and say I
want to participate in this cohort in
fact during the State of the Union my
mom for in who lives in st. Paul Owen is
has number of chronic conditions but
including rheumatoid arthritis typed
with a stylus on her iPad an email
message to me gear in the state of the
union saying that she wants to join this
cohort so we have to make a way for
anybody to be able to participate not
just because of my mom but because it's
the right thing to do and that is going
to be a distinct challenge in something
we've never really tried to do before so
as a part of building this cohort we
have some core values one is that the
cohort is open to anyone who is
interested that we want to reflect the
rich diversity of the united states that
we want participants as partners in all
phases of the program we want to make
sure that data is available and data
sharing is really the legacy of the
genome project where it was our ambition
then to make sure that any researcher
anywhere with an internet connection
could get the genome sequence we have
the same ambition here but we're also
including participants as individuals
who should have access to study
information and that is certainly not
the case for much of the research that
we do we do the research we click the
biospecimens we learn new things that we
don't often
intentionally returned all that
information back to participants so in
collecting this information we need to
make sure that we have the right kind of
data security and privacy principles in
place the White House has developed
privacy principles and tomorrow will
probably be announcing draft security
principles as well that are really key
to this the other thing that has been
particularly interesting along the way
as we've designed this program is that
the core values here and the core
policies that we need to have in place
to make this program work really are
leading the way for the kinds of
policies that we need to have in place
for other biomedical research programs
as well and respect for research
participants is really at the core and
I'm going to do a little digression here
and say a word about how dr. Collins
who's pictured here and I really got
sort of inspired to think about research
participants truly as partners and that
was through our work with the family of
henrietta lacks and you all may remember
that the sequence of the HeLa cells was
deciphered and published on a publicly
accessible website mirrored by our own
NCBI and that took the family by
surprise and it was quite the stir in
the Twittersphere about that and we
ended up working with the family over a
period of time to make that sequence
available but also to bring them into
the decision-making process and so this
picture of me taking a picture of
France's taking a selfie of himself with
two of the lacs Henrietta Lacks
grandchildren Jerry and David and their
mom was on the day that we announced
this new partnership and they've really
been inspirational to us in designing
the precision medicine initiative I
mentioned that there had been a survey
of public opinion and a summary of some
of the key findings is here
we're hoping to have it as published
soon and make the full data set
available as well but what you can see
is that overwhelmingly people think that
the cohort probably or definitely should
be done and then a slim majority say
that they would probably or definitely
participate in a cohort and of course
that doesn't mean what people say
they'll do and what they actually do
doesn't always align but that's a good
indicator most interesting was that when
asked about a whole series of potential
motivations for participate
participation though the number one
reason that people indicated they wanted
to participate is to receive results and
information from the study so I'm going
to skip this slide so our goal is to
have information flowing through the
health care provider partnered
volunteers the people in green here and
through our direct volunteers the people
in blue and that they would provide this
core initial data set into a central
biorepository and we have applications
in now to from folks who are eager to
help us build that biorepository and
data will be provided into a secure
Enclave that will be available for
researchers and of course over time that
data set will grow just a word about the
biospecimens and the biobank we want to
make sure that people provide adequate
consent for future uses of those
biospecimens we're going to start with
blood but will probably grow to have
other kinds of biospecimens over time
and we'll make sure that that is
compliant with all of the necessary
rules and regulations so that results
from analysis of those vestments can be
returned to the individual research
participants so while we're going to
start with that limited data set over
time we think that that can grow and
some of the potential additional kinds
of data that we might be able to add on
are listed here we have solicited for
and received applications for
technology a participant Technology
Center and that will that centers job
will be to help us in identifying and
validating and deploying mobile health
and other kinds of sensors in the cohort
and being able to use those kinds of
data as well and so that's an exciting
an exciting aspect so I mentioned the
data flow out data will be flowing both
out for research and those research
results will flow back in and
information will be flown to the
participants themselves and over time
that set of data will grow I talked
about returning results to individuals
and we really want to be able to let
people set their own preferences about
what they want so some people want
everything and they want to know
everything I am NOT a data lover myself
so I would only probably want
information when I want to go seek it
myself rather than being pinged with
information all the time others want to
know everything in real time and will
let people set their own preferences
about that I mentioned in how this is a
catalyst for policy advances and have
been really pleased in being able to
work really hard on advancing some of
these policies so one policy is and I'm
sure for researchers who are listening
the frustration of participating in a
multi-site study and having to wait for
multiple different I rbs to provide back
there often inconsistent views about
your research protocol and your
employment
instruments can really delay research
and we are moving broadly to try to
remove that as a barrier so we have put
forward a policy that we will require a
single IRB for multi-site studies funded
by the NIH will be finalizing that
policy this spring but for the precision
medicine initiative we have already put
together a single IRB and we'll be
announcing the members of that IRB
tomorrow um we have to have good strong
privacy and security principles i
mentioned that those are going to also
be made public tomorrow the security
principles we need to make sure that we
can share results back to individuals
and that requires that we have some
alignment between clear requirements
Clinical Laboratory Improvement
Amendments and HIPAA requirements and
we're working very hard on that and then
we're also going to have to address the
issues of if we're really going to allow
and encourage everyone from all life
stages and ages to participate we're
going to have to figure out how to
really robustly include families and
children people who are or become too
decision Leah impaired during the course
of the study and participants who may
become incarcerated during the course of
the cohort so on we have also in keeping
with our notion of participants as
partners we will have participants
involved in all aspects of the PMI
cohort program governance and a snapshot
of that is here we are actively in the
process of trying to hire a PMI program
director and we hope to have that person
in place very shortly and most of these
advisory groups have already been
established and they are comprised of a
third to a half of people who are either
prospective participant or participant
representatives so our timeline here has
been quite rapid and unusually where
I've been for the federal government
say so in January last the president
launched this initiative we put together
our working group we got the
recommendations we put out funding
opportunity announcements we got the
applications in for all of those and we
are going to make tomorrow an
announcement of our first awards so our
timeline up until December of 2016 and
that's an important date for some of us
it's certainly an important date for the
president whose initiative who launched
this initiative and so we hope by
December of 20 of this year to have
seventy nine thousand individuals
enrolled in the cohort program skip over
that so I want to talk a little bit
about this first phase and the steps
that we are taking to figure out really
to experiment in how to invite people to
participate and how to keep them engaged
and certainly this is not a new issue
it's an old issue but we don't do such a
good job of this in biomedical research
we don't do a great job of what we say
recruiting probably not the best word
recruiting people into clinical trials
in fact we suck at it and so we want to
learn through this cohort program how to
do that better and how to have true
partnership I'm going to speed along
here because I see that it is almost
1230 and we want to have ample time for
questions so I'm going to zip along a
little bit here and say that we did put
out these funding announcements and they
were both for engagement effort and a
direct volunteer effort you want to say
just a word about the direct volunteer
pilot because that's really critical we
need to figure out how to set up a
portal where anybody in the united
states including my mom importantly can
access information about the cohort sign
up to be in the cohort provide their
informed consent
and provide information over the course
of time and get information back and
that's a significant challenge and I'm
going to skip along here a little bit
and talk about the direct volunteer
pilot so we will be tomorrow announcing
this first award for a direct volunteer
pilot studies and this is really to
develop this participant interface to
optimize ways to get people engaged and
to keep them engaged over the long haul
and so we're really excited to have been
able to put out the solicitation for
this opportunity that we got really
exciting applications and with all sorts
of interesting partnerships and we'll be
making that first award tomorrow and
we're using a non-traditional way to
make that when we first announced these
funding opportunities when was it was in
November we got the applications in in
December we reviewed them in January and
we're making the award in February
that's breathtaking pace for us when I
was announcing that at a conference in
San Francisco a tool beaut was in the
audience and he tweeted why so fast and
I tweeted later that the president was
impatient and we are too so I actually
think we're sort of setting the stage
for being able to do things and a more
rapid more flexible more number way here
at NIH I'm excited about that and we are
also going to be announcing tomorrow our
pilots at the federally qualified health
centers really awesomely exciting and
then in June and July we will be making
announcements of coordinating centers
which have huge task as a part of that
precision medicine initiative some of
those key functions listed here we will
also be announcing in June and July the
healthcare provider organizations we
hope to name between five and seven of
these as our partners and bringing in
their patient populations in their
communities to be volunteers in the
cohort and then the participant
Technology Center
and bio Bank which are going to be key
to the infrastructure for the
biospecimens and for developing and
deploying mobile health technologies and
sensors so this is our general in
general our timeline for moving forward
with these activities it's pretty
exciting the direct volunteer pilot
launching tomorrow and then over the
period of the next month's through
December being able to enroll these
79,000 people initially with modest data
set but that data set will grow over
time and we think that data will be
invaluable in real time this year for
researchers but principally for asking
important questions about how to engage
in partner with research participants so
this is a snapshot of things that we
hope to have done over the course of the
next several months we want to have the
direct volunteer engagement and
enrollment pilot completed we want to be
able to use those results to design and
launch the scale up over the direct
fallen to your program we want to have
strong partnerships with five to seven
healthcare provider organizations we
will have implemented and tested this
exciting partnership with federally
qualified health centers we'll have our
first set our pioneer participants in
the cohort enrolled and we hope to have
biospecimens collected and start to have
some real ability for direct volunteers
specifically to be able to obtain and
then to direct to research including PMI
research the contents of their
electronic health records and working a
the announcing tomorrow pilot award that
we're making which we call seat for
science which would enable participants
who have electronic health records to be
able to access the information from
their EHR and then to point it to to a
research program including 2pm I and
then by the end of the year we'll have a
functioning data platform that will have
awesome security and awesome data access
both at the same time
and that we hope to have a number of
research studies using these data
already underway so that is in a
snapshot what we have managed to do so
far and what we're hoping to do I will
conclude by saying that it is on the
president's publicly available schedule
that he is having an event about
precision medicine tomorrow it's going
to be webcast live from the White House
between 10 and 12 its promises to be an
extraordinarily exciting morning and in
fact today and we're going to have a
party in the afternoon after all the
announcements have been made and so
please check that out I'm not exactly
sure what the URL is for that but if you
follow me I will tweet that URL out as
soon as I get it so with that Kevin I am
going to i think throw this back to you
or not Cathy hi thank you so much what a
fantastic keynote presentation and yes
we have plenty of questions to get to so
I hope you can stick around for another
10 minutes or so I thought you're going
to invite us all to the party tomorrow
so maybe we'll look for that invitation
on Twitter as well we can hope so yes we
have a dozen or so questions at least
from the audience and I want to get to
them straight away let's say i want to
thank patricia say bald from the
boothbay region health and wellness
foundation up in maine i believe for a
fusillade of questions which i will
quickly rattle through and you were you
may need a pen and paper here Kathy to
catch all these but it's basically a
serious she's probing what patients will
have access to so among her great
questions are will patients have access
to the analysis of their purse
genomes understandable explanations of
what the analysis reveals will they know
what subgroup of patients they have been
clustered with will they be able to add
and share additional clinical or
lifestyle information to to improve the
health records and make it easier for
researchers using data analysis to spot
new patterns will they be notified when
new finding arises that impacts people
in their genotype or phenotype and will
they be able to connect with other
patients who share a similar genetic
traits and diseases let me leave it
there and pass it back to you so I'm
waiting to be connected I hope I'm live
okay so I'm going to try to answer I'm
going to try to answer that question by
talking a little bit about the genomics
component because I think this is really
important so first the precision
medicine cohort is about more than jeans
and certainly more than genes play an
important role in our helped and and and
well-being so the cohort program is
going to collect wide variety of data
much more broadly than genomics we
really would like and given my
background and given Francis's
background were eager to be able to do
genomics within the cohort but we also
understand that because we are
anticipating giving that data back that
we have to do that with extraordinary
intentionality so the issue of
returnable results has been one that has
been debated and discussed for over a
decade and we don't have been frankly a
perfect answer to what data should be
returned and how should it be returned
and what will people do with it but I
think that our general premise is that
people can make informed decisions about
what to do with information and that if
we have the data they have a right to it
so that's sort of the starting platform
but it also means that we want to that's
probably not the first thing we're going
to do out of the box frankly so we're
not going to do whole genome sequencing
as the first set of analysis
and that when we do the first set of
genomic analysis we want to have it
something that can provide value to
everyone and that means providing value
to the participants themselves so I
mentioned the pharmacogenetic Merkers
has been particularly attractive and
something that would be useful both for
the participants but also for us because
a lot of these variants could be more
broadly validated in a bigger population
and new variants identified so in terms
of will we do whole genome sequencing
yes but not out of the starting gate and
now of course I quickly lost what the
rest of the questions were so I'm going
to toss it Kevin back to you and say
that I at least answered part of one
question
let me just thank you Cathy let me just
repeat one of the other elements of the
question which i think is interesting is
will there be any sort of social
networking or contact between
participants I think Matt perhaps the
question is alluding to the likes of
patients like me where you can sort of
identify in spots and perhaps even
correspond with people who are in the
same boat as you where the gym typically
or phenotypically back to you so I
anticipate that there will be an
extraordinarily rich social network or
networks that are built as we begin this
and I think that's going to be one of
the interesting things that we can
explore with the direct volunteer pilots
is people's interest in participating in
such a network and then as we build the
cohort actually doing some
experimentation around how do those
social networks work and what is the
sort of the effect of participating in
those social networks through PMI
overall on people's ongoing engagement
and perhaps on their behaviors and with
health outcomes we certainly know that
there are a gazillion mobile health
devices out there and fitness related
devices we don't really know what impact
they have on individuals health outcomes
over the long term and similarly we know
some about people's participation in
social networks and health-related
social networks but being able to do
this at scale I should provide some
really interesting information and so we
hope to explore that but we were looking
at the good ideas that are being brought
in by our applicants and the best brains
who are coming to be our partner so
we'll learn more about that as we go a
lot of people Kathy including me
understandably curious at how they can
volunteer so you touched on that but
will there be a portal or a website that
they will be able to just sign up how
will that work so that's a great
question and in some ways the direct
volunteer program is going to help us
with that the pilot program is going to
help us think through that so I think
what we're going to do with the direct
volunteers is explore the portal and how
to build it so that people will be
engaged and learn how to do that with a
controlled audience and then the
question that you're asking is then how
do you scale and how do you do a real
launch of open the ability of anyone to
be able to participate and this raises
all sorts of interesting questions about
whether or not there are campaigns
within specific communities that would
you know flood the precision medicine
initiative with certain kinds of people
so we have to think carefully about if
we really are going to reflect the rich
diversity of the United States we need
to think carefully about that outreach
and engagement and so we are asking we
have asked for help with that through a
communications and engagement
solicitation and we're going to make
that award this week and those folks are
going to help us figure out how to do
this in a careful and successful way and
as we do this we need to make sure that
we are uber transparent about
expectations both on expectations about
what will we need from you as a
participant if you're going to sign up
to a volunteer and what can you expect
to get back and importantly what do we
think we will learn from the cohort and
I think having sort of expectations
set appropriately and realistically
across all of the ecosystem that
researchers the health care providers
and the participants is going to be
super critical at the get-go so that
people don't end up being disappointed
or annoyed or feel let down from this
from this undertaking back to you Kevin
you need to make sure you still have a
voice for the big announcement tomorrow
so let's just a rapid fire Cathy just to
quickly go through a few more questions
from the audience here in the next five
minutes or so just back to the direct
volunteers have you thought about using
facebook or other social media to
recruit tools either in this first phase
or perhaps as you scale up that's you so
um we do want to use social media to
recruit but I think we're probably not
going to do that in this very first
phase with the pilots and the reason for
that is if sort of my pulse taking is
any indication is that there's an
enormous amount of enthusiasm and so if
we said for the pilots that we were
going to have a wide open opportunity to
participate I think we would have
thousands if not tens of thousands of
people signed up in about five minutes
so in the volunteer direct volunteer
pilot phase which will last for a year
we will we will have a consortium when
we launch the direct volunteer program
will segue from the pilots into the
full-scale launch during the course of
the pilot program we're really going to
have to map out the ways in which we
reach out to people through social media
through community organ
some of this is going to have to be I
think pretty grassroots if we're really
going to reach people in every nook and
cranny across across the country its
back to you comin Kent Lloyd has not
read such a question as a statement but
I'm curious if you have any reaction to
it perhaps it's not relevant but it's
interesting nonetheless the direct
volunteer pilots he says is an
opportunity to include the uninsured and
to direct them to obtain coverage
through the Affordable Care Act a way to
leverage the impact of the of the
precision medicine initiative cohort
program with increasing healthcare
coverage across the nation has there
been any thought to potentially linking
those two elements back to you Kathy so
I have to say that the way in which we
have thought about the launch of the
Affordable Care Act and and the getting
people enrolled and health care programs
has been more related to the
unsuccessful initial launch of that
program and what can we learn about what
kind of processes we need to put in
place to kick the tires to make sure
that we have the capability the user
focused design that we have everything
all the bugs worked out before we go
live so that's the way in which we
thought about it most that the issue
here though is really important so for
people who are uninsured or underinsured
if they are volunteering into this
cohort we need to think very carefully
about what responsibilities and
obligations ethically we have to those
participants if they have themselves
health conditions when they walk in the
door or log on and if those indicators
biomarkers signs or symptoms of
disorders are
identified two in the course of the
program so for people in the hbos in the
health care provider organizations
that's presumably not an issue but for
direct volunteers this is a substantial
issue I'm one in which we are eager to
have robust conversations and
discussions with all of you and with the
people who are participating in the
pilot the direct volunteer pilot I don't
think we have yet an adequate answer and
we certainly will have to have a very
adequate more than adequate answer
before we go live in large-scale direct
volunteer program Kevin thanks Kathy do
you see epigenetics being part of the
precision medicine initiative like to
you absolutely although again like the
genomic analysis I think we're going to
wait a little bit of time before we
deploy that into the cohort but for a
couple reasons some pragmatic and and
well all pragmatic so we need to build a
bio bank before we can collect
biospecimens and before we can do
analysis of biospecimens so there's that
sort of built-in lag and we want to
understand in exquisite detail what the
participants in the cohort are
interested in having done done with
their specimens and how they want that
information back and so we need to
figure that out before we can think
about doing epigenomics in the in the
cohort I should also say quickly that
there will be core data collection
through the cohort and core laboratory
analyses performed within the cohort and
then there will be the opportunity to
use this as a platform for many many
many other studies and you could imagine
all sorts of ways in which you could use
a national cohort of a million or more
people to advance science so it could be
the basis of recruiting a sub co
Court of people who have specific
phenotypes or genotypes that you want to
engage in a specific clinical trial for
example you might want to gain access to
biospecimens from individuals with
specific characteristics all of those
things will be possible because our
participants as our partners will have
provided or can provide because we're in
ongoing contact with them their
permission to participate in sub studies
or entirely new studies based on their
interest or some other characteristic
about them so I think that's one of the
really exciting things and we're hoping
you know this is a disease agnostic
research cohort so so all of the
Institute's and centers that the
National Institutes of Health are
interested and enthusiastic about this
cohort and over time as we get it built
we hope that they will provide funding
through their own mechanisms for
researchers and their research
communities to do studies that leverage
and make use of this national research
cohort Kevin thanks Kathy I'm going to
sneak in one more question and then you
can you can sign off and with any final
thoughts as they say in the debates and
I'll wrap up earlier this morning
earlier today at the precision medicine
virtual event here we we heard from tim
Hubbard from genomics England and
obviously particular Europe and some
other places there have been efforts
over a number of years now in bio
banking and genomic repositories of
small nations that arguably have blazed
the trail that we are belatedly
following over here I'm just curious if
you could say a little bit more about
how much you're collaborating and
learning from some of these trailblazing
efforts in not just the UK but Estonia
and Iceland which of course grappled
with questions such as genomic privacy
for example thank to you
so that's a great question and we
certainly do want to learn from all
those trailblazers who have gone before
us although we do think that we are
different and distinct unique and
awesome but we for example had as one of
our PMI working group members Lori
Collins who is the head of the UK
biobank different in its design it
recruited people who were 4269 I think
with the anticipation that you would
have a higher number of individuals who
had diseases that you were interested in
and therefore you'd have more power to
study individual diseases earlier on
we're not going to take exactly that
approach we have in the process of
building the program have looked very
carefully at what has been done with
other cohorts around the world and we
want to figure out ways in which to stay
engaged with those cohorts over time so
that's going to be an interesting and
exciting aspect of this the other thing
is that where there are existing
instruments or analyses that have been
done usefully in other cohorts we
certainly want to be able to adopt those
so for example the million veterans
program the UK biobank and others have
asked people questions and so to the
extent that we can collect data that is
comparable to the data that have been
collected in other cohorts that would be
fantastic and powerful and then there
are also small cohorts like Google
baseline for example which are much
deeper than our cohort is and to the
extent that there are interesting assays
or interesting tools that they use or
develop in the course of those smaller
cohorts that are validated within those
cohorts we might then import those over
time so I think we really need to learn
from others both large cohorts large and
small it sounds a little bit like dr.
Seuss Kevin back to you
okay well Kathy that will have to be the
last word I won't send it back to you
for final thoughts because of the the
time lag but thank you so much on behalf
of everybody tuning in both live now and
on demand there'll be many many more
I've no doubt and we look forward to
your big announcement tomorrow we're
glad to have had this sneak peek that
was Kathy Hudson our second keynote
speaker at the inaugural precision
medicine virtual event hosted by lab
roots on the scene Ian media group she's
direct Deputy Director for science
outreach and policy and a chief
architect of the precision medicine
initiative so you've heard it all here
you can follow her on Twitter at Kathy
Hudson NIH she plugs her Twitter account
several times and so if we didn't have
time to get to your questions I'm sure
she won't mind if you ping her on
Twitter and I'm sure she'll try to get
back to you as time allows today's
webcast is on da labelled on demand for
another six months through August of
2016 and we'll let you know when that's
that's available I just want to finally
in closing thank all the folks at lab
roots for making this platform works so
well and our sponsors in particular
horizon technology kyochon soma logic
alumina lease pro and Helmer they've
made this event possible please go visit
them in the exhibit hall and see what
what's how they're engaging with the
precision medicine community please stay
tuned for another great talk at the top
of the hour when we'll hear from aya
Khalil my friend and founder of gns
healthcare up in Boston a brilliant
speaker and many more speakers to come
so we have everybody involved in the
inaugural virtual symposium on precision
medicine thanks for watching I'm Kevin
Davis for CNN we appreciate you joining
us and bye for now